this story has to do with our friend
lebron james
okay and lebron's
ma
nay so basically he opens up about his
kids growing up
filthy rich and he basically says he
wants them to have some hardships in
their life right this is a bro bible
story that's true so you know how much
money lebron is going to make this year
this year alone 100 million bucks if not
more all right that's between on and off
the court yeah i think on the court he
makes like 40 million and then off the
court he's getting be another
60-something million endorsements
sponsorships everything if that guy
drops a grand it is literally not worth
his time to turn around and pick it up
touche
um
and i don't think he's a billionaire yet
but i think forbes is projecting him to
hit billionaire status
uh in the coming
days weeks or months right that's how
that's that's how he's doing right
but if you go back
right so lebron's been in the league
since maybe oh
so you go late you go 90s
right he's been a lot around for you go
90s you know he grew up in the projects
of cleveland yeah and he says quote
unquote i saw drugs guns murder
killings it was crazy
but now
he's living in a 23 million los angeles
home he's killing it obviously he's
making 100 million dollars a year he's a
billionaire
and he says now
you know after everything i saw with the
murder the killings and all that
um
my kids the only killings you know that
they're seeing in their childhood is if
they're playing call of duty in the
private theater of my house yeah okay
yeah so the question that he was trying
to answer lebron
is how does he ensure that his kids
don't grow up soft
how does he how does he grow up how does
he ensure that his kids don't
grow up being the do you know who my
daddy is that play in that car i think
it's impossible at this point it's
possible not to yeah i mean you're
lebron [ __ ] james well here's what
he's your kid is your kid's name is
brawny brownie that's true he can't not
really but you know he doesn't look they
don't have to say like there's a reason
that you know what's tony robbins son's
name
uh tony robbins jr what is it yeah it's
irrelevant because the guy does not have
that it quality right these guys who
make something like like the gary vees
of the world yeah or the tony robbins of
the world or the mark cubans of the
world or the steve jobs of the world
a lot of times their kids
you never really hear about them because
they don't have that same
passion that drives like yo i gotta do
some [ __ ] right that same work ethic
right the same drive i see what you're
saying right right
so it's the silver spoon effect you
these rich kids they don't turn out to
be much because they're not hungry
stay hungry stay foolish so here's what
lebron says about his kids he says
there's absolutely nothing
i can do to give them the same momentum
aspirations or drive that i had we just
touched on that the one thing i can do
is instill the morals
and what we do in this house and this is
how you need to represent yourself when
you leave the house you give them the
blueprint
i hope they have some adversity though i
hope they have some adversity though
this is his words they need some
hardships the best teacher in life is
experience how about that yeah lebron
wants his kids to go through hardships
look regardless of how you feel about
lebron you know he's got a political
agenda and a social agenda
you got to respect this dude we all have
a political and social that's true
you got to respect this dude not just as
a basketball player but as a man as a
father you never see his name in the
tabloids of
issues off the court fighting with his
wife internal drama the dude's a g
you got to give him that becoming a
billionaire okay
so you know what i love about what he's
saying is that he wants his kids to have
some adversity yeah lebron wants his
kids to go through some hardships yeah
you need them right your kids need to
earn it
your kids you know you could obviously
you want to make your life easier for
them but nothing
nothing is worse than soft
pampered kids dude that can't hack it in
the real world oh my daddy will bail me
out
yeah there's nothing worse than that and
that's what lebron's saying like look
my kids are growing up wealthy they're
grown up rich they're living in mansions
the only killings that are seen are
potentially on call of duty but i want
them to struggle i want them to pay the
price for greatness yeah right yeah it's
something you need man louisike made a
great joke about this where he's what'd
louise say louis i think he said on late
night he's like you know of course
they're going to be [ __ ] they don't
know any like they don't know anything
bad and like i think this just happens
like every generation like your kids
will have a better childhood than you
did right
of course i think that's the whole goal
is to give your kids a better childhood
i like where you're going with this you
want to give your kids a better
childhood but at the same time you want
them to have the same
drive or aspirations that you have like
i love what pat does with his kids
clearly they're killing it they're
having to live in a great house
but his kids need to earn it whether
that's reading whether that's doing
chores whether it's paying the price to
do something you want to have fun you
need to do this first
like lebron said i can instill the
morals of what we do in this house and
how to represent yourself when you leave
the house that's all you can do look
here's the bottom line
going through some [ __ ] is what makes us
who we are yeah what was our our guy
today two tulum
oh my god what a story
with this guy dvd podcast episode 96
unbelievable pressure makes diamonds the
room quiet for a solid 10 minutes i was
that's the most intense guy ever yeah so
look um
if you
at home are going through some [ __ ]
it's so easy to feel bad for yourself i
can't tell you especially if you live in
the united states
how much
better we have it here than anywhere
else in this world yeah i can't explain
that to you when i see these people like
two come on the show and basically say
that he was almost killed in vietnam
just for being a
not a communist and what he had to go
through
man i appreciate being in america
man i just at the freedom forum down um
in miami interviewing
people from north korea iran iraq
um russia
bosnia i like people from all over the
world and
you know the one thing
that
he's he's basically the host of the
daily show in iraq just to put in
perspective okay he said you know what i
want for the people in iraq
i want them to be worried
about
their favorite reality show character
i pray that that's what they're worried
about oh what does that mean
he goes
when you're not worried about a bomb
dropping on your head
or you know isis knocking down your door
and your only worry is
who's getting kicked off relationship
island number seven yeah man life's good
[ __ ] dude yeah and i was like damn
damn bro he's like yeah because uh isis
literally wants to kill me this is what
he's telling me he's like isis they
don't like me too much dude
and so that's what it is so if you're
going through some [ __ ] look
um it's going to make you who you are
yeah you're going to use that as your
backstory you're going to say when i was
younger this is what happened to me and
damn that's how i made it yeah pat
constantly talks about leaving in iran
um the shah everything that happened
with the revolution um
living in a um
in a
refugee camp in germany coming to
america basically getting [ __ ] on
when he first came here getting made fun
of calling him a towel head whatever
they called him
look at that guy now yeah you don't
think that guy had some adversity and
some challenges say yo i'm gonna do some
[ __ ] that's the drive that's the drive
so that's what lebron wants for his kids
so i don't know how he's gonna
manufacture that that's the thing how do
you i don't know
i don't know
um you cut them off from credit cards
and then it's like i [ __ ] hate my dad
you know his kids are lebron's basically
in his mantering wondering how he could
basically have his kids go through some
[ __ ] like and i i wonder i wonder like
if he has like just bratty kids like
mike i don't know based on his track
record and his the family environment i
think i think um he's raising a good
family and that's what i wanted to give
lebron a shot we talk his money
all we talk is money
if you enjoyed that short clip from the
sauce cast click here to watch another
click here to watch the full episode or
just stay broken